[Music]
when most people think about the
beginnings of AIDS they're gonna think
back to the 1980s and certainly this was
the decade in which we discovered AIDS
and the virus that causes at HIV but in
fact this virus crossed over into humans
many decades before from chimpanzees
where the virus originated into humans
who hunt these apes this photo was taken
before the Great Depression
in Brazzaville Congo at this time there
were tens of thousands of individuals we
think they were infected with HIV so I
have a couple of really important
questions for you if this virus was in
tens or hundreds of thousands of
individuals at this point why was it the
case that it took us until 1984 to be
able to discover this virus okay now
more importantly had we been there in
the 40s and 50s 60s had we seen this
disease had we understood exactly what
was going on with that how might that
have changed and completely transformed
the nature of the way that this pandemic
moved in fact this is not unique to HIV
the vast majority of viruses come from
animals and you can kind of think of
this as a pyramid of this bubbling up of
viruses from animals into human
populations but only at the very top of
this pyramid do these things become
completely human nevertheless we spend
the vast majority of our energy focused
on this level of the pyramid trying to
tackle things that are already
completely adapted to human beings that
are going to be very very difficult to
address as we've seen in the case of HIV
so during the last 15 years I've been
working to actually study the earlier
interface here what I've labeled viral
chatter which was a term coined by my
mentor Dan Burke this is the idea that
we can study the sort of pinging of
these viruses into human populations the
movement of these agents over into
humans and by capturing this moment we
might be able to move to a situation
where we can catch them early okay so
this is a picture and I'm going to show
you some pictures now from the field
this is a picture of a Central African
hunter it's actually a fairly common
picture one of the things I want you to
note from it is blood that you see a
tremendous amount of blood contact this
was absolutely key for us this is a very
intimate form of connection so if we're
going to study viral chatter we need to
get to these populations who have
intensive
contact with wild animals and so we've
been studying people like this
individual we collect blood from them
other specimens we look at the diseases
which are in the animals as well as the
humans and ideally this is gonna allow
us to catch these things early on as
they're moving over into human
populations and the basic objective of
this work is not to just go out once and
look at these individuals but to
establish thousands of individuals in
these populations that we would monitor
continuously on a regular basis when
they were sick we would collect
specimens from them we would actually
enlist them which we've done now to
collect specimens from animals we give
them these little pieces of filter paper
when they sample from animals they
collect the blood on the filter paper
and this allows us to identify yet
unknown viruses from exactly the right
animals the ones that are actually being
hunted deep in a remote region of
Cameroon two hunters stalk their prey
their names are Patrice and petite
they're searching for bush meat forest
animals they can kill to feed their
families Patrice and pettite set out
most days to go out hunting in the
forest around their homes they have a
series of traps of snares that they've
set up and catch wild pigs snakes
monkeys rodents anything they can really
Patrice and p'tee have been out for
hours but found nothing
the animals are simply gone we stopped
for a drink of water then there's a
rustle in the brush the group of hunters
approached their packs loaded with wild
game
there's at least three viruses that you
know about which are in this particular
one case this species yeah and there's
many many more pathogens that are
present in these animals these
individuals are at specific risk
particularly if there's blood contact
they're at risk for transmission and
possibly infection with novel viruses as
the hunters display their kills
something surprising happens they show
us filter paper they've used to collect
the animals blood the blood will be
tested for ZOA notic viruses part of a
program doctor wolf has spent years
setting up so this is from this animal
right here greater spot knows guenon
every person who has one of those filter
papers is at least at a minimum been
through our basic health education about
the risks associated with these
activities which presumably from our
perspective gives them the ability to
decrease their own risk and then
obviously the risk to their families the
village the country and the world okay
before I continue I think it's important
to take just a moment to talk about bush
meat bush meat is the hunting of wild
game okay and you can consider all sorts
of different bush meat I'm gonna be
talking about this when your children
and grandchildren sort of pose questions
to you about this period of time one of
the things they're gonna ask you is how
it was that we allowed some of our
closest living relatives some of the
most valuable and dangerous species on
our planet to go extinct because we
weren't able to address some of the
issues of poverty in these parts of the
world but in fact that's not the only
question they're gonna ask you about
this they're also going to ask you the
question that when we knew that this was
the way that HIV entered into the human
population and that other diseases had
the potential to enter like this why did
we let these behaviors continue why did
we not find some other solution to this
they're gonna say in regions of profound
instability throughout the world where
you have intense poverty where
populations are growing and you don't
have sustainable resource
like this this is going to lead to food
insecurity but they're also going to ask
you probably a different question it's
one that I think we all need to ask
ourselves which is why we thought the
responsibility rested with this
individual here now this is the
individual you can see just right up
over his right shoulder this is the
individual that hunted the monkey from
the last picture that I showed you okay
take a look at his shirt you know take a
look at his face
bushmeat is one of the central crises
which is occurring in our population
right now in humanity on this planet but
it can't be the fault of somebody like
this okay and solving it cannot be his
responsibility alone there's no easy
solutions but what I'm saying to you is
that we neglect this problem at our own
peril so in 1998 along with my mentors
Don Burke and Cornel and pootie and
Golay we went to actually start this
work in central Africa to work with
hunters in this part of the world and my
job at that time I was a postdoctoral
fellow and I was really tasked with
setting this up so I said to myself okay
great we're gonna collect all kinds of
specimens we're gonna go to all these
different locations it's gonna be
wonderful you know I looked at the map I
picked out 17 sites I figured no problem
needless to say I was drastically wrong
this is challenging work to do
fortunately I had and continue to have
an absolutely wonderful team of
colleagues and collaborators in my own
team and that's the only way that this
work can really occur we have a whole
range of challenges about this work one
of them is just obtaining trust from
individuals that we work with in the
field the person you see on the right
hand side is Paul DeLong minuto he's one
of the best communicators that I've
really ever dealt with when I arrived I
didn't speak a word of French and I
still seemed to understand what it was
he was saying Paul worked for years on
the Cameroonian national radio and
television and he spoke about health
issues he was a health correspondent so
we figured we'd hire this person when we
got there he could be a great
communicator when we would get to these
rural villages that what we found out is
that no one had television so they
wouldn't recognize his face but when he
began to speak they would actually
recognize his voice from the radio and
this was somebody who had incredible
potential to spread aspects of our
message whether it be with regards to
wildlife conservation or
health prevention often we run into
obstacles this is us coming back from
one of these very rural sites with
specimens from 200 individuals that we
needed to get back to the lab within 48
hours I'd like to show this shot this is
a Baltimore Faye who's the lead
investigator and our camera insight who
Bob laughs to me when I show this photo
because of course you can't see his face
but the reason I like to show the shot
is because you can see that he's about
to solve this problem which which he did
which he did just a few quick
before-and-after shots this was our
laboratory before this is what it looks
like now early on in order to ship our
specimens we had to have dry ice to get
dry ice we had to go to the breweries
beg borrow steal to get these folks to
give it to us now we have our own liquid
nitrogen I'd like to call our laboratory
the coldest place in Central Africa it
might be and here's a shot of me this is
the before shot of me no comment so what
happened so during the 10 years that
we've been doing this work we actually
surprised ourselves we've made a number
of discoveries and what we found is that
if you look in the right place you can
actually monitor the flow of these
viruses into human populations that gave
us a tremendous amount of hope what we
found is a whole range of new viruses in
these individuals including new viruses
in the same group as HIV so brand new
retroviruses and let's face at any new
retrovirus in the human population it's
something we should be aware of it's
something we should be following it's
not something that we should be
surprised by and needless to say in the
past these viruses entering into these
rural communities might very well have
gone extinct that's no longer the case
logging roads provide access to urban
areas and critically what happens in
Central Africa doesn't stay in central
Africa so once we discovered that it was
really possible that we could actually
do this monitoring we decided to move
this from research to really attempt to
phase up to a global monitoring effort
and through generous support and
partnership scientifically with
google.org and the school foundation we
were able to start the global viral
forecasting initiative and begin work in
four different sites in Africa and Asia
needless to say
from populations from different parts of
the world have different sorts of
contact so it's not just hunters in
central Africa it's also working in live
animal markets these wet markets which
is exactly the place where SARS emerged
in Asia but really this is just the
beginning from our perspective our
objective right now in addition to
deploying to these sites and getting
everything moving is to identify new
partners because we feel like this
effort needs to be extended to probably
20 or more sites throughout the world's
to viral hotspots because really the
idea here is to cast an incredibly wide
net so that we can catch these things
ideally before they make it to blood
banks sexual networks airplanes and
that's really our objective there was a
time not very long ago when the
discovery of unknown organisms was
something that held incredible off for
us it had potential to really change the
way that we saw ourselves and thought
about ourselves many people I think on
our planet right now despair and they
think we've reached a point where we've
discovered most of the things I'm going
to tell you right now please don't
despair if an intelligent
extraterrestrial was tasked with writing
the encyclopedia of life on our planet
27 out of 30 of these volumes would be
devoted to bacteria and virus with just
a few of the volumes left for plants
fungus and animals humans being a
footnote an interesting footnote but a
footnote nonetheless this is honestly
the most exciting period ever for the
study of unknown life forms on our
planet the dominant things that exist
here we know almost nothing about and
yet finally we have the tools which will
allow us to actually explore that world
and understand them thank you very much
[Applause]
it says to wait until 10:00 p.m.
it only takes what it needs it's powered
from far away it talks with the others
with the smart grid energy is more
intelligent than ever now we can manage
electricity more efficiently save money
by using energy at off-peak hours and
even distribute alternative energy from
one part of the country to another
simply by listening to what the smart
grid has to say the smart grid it's all
around us
[Music]